[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis
weltreise geht es ein mediterranes
rezept ich habe einen braten gemacht aus
dem backofen das ganze ist ein bisschen
mediterran orientalisch daher wird es
jetzt kate genannt und ich habe das für
rindfleisch benutzt dazu gibt es gemüse
als paprika gemüse und hier okay dass
ich ein bisschen typisch deutsch muss
ich sagen bratkartoffeln und ich finde
ich einfach gigantisch ist jetzt ohne so
große chin chin irgendwas ein richtig
geniale beraten kartoffel in der pfanne
angebraten richtig würzig und sie dazu
als ohne dieses chin chin und ach was
was mache ich hier noch rein fenchel
anis kümmel du kannst noch wissen weiter
her rennen philosophieren ich zeige euch
jetzt mal die zutaten die ich benötige
und zwar werden wir zuerst den braten zu
bereiten
und es ist auch ein richtig tolles
rezept man kann es wieder super
vorbereiten in den ofen schieben und in
der zwischenzeit einfach die kartoffeln
machen also los gehts hier sind die
zutaten
ich brauche 323 paprikaschoten da habe
ich jetzt rot gelb und grün sechs
esslöffel einen halben teelöffel salz
und im titelthema verfahren ich habe
mich jetzt das fleisch dann nämlich
knapp zwei kilo rinder hans und hier die
gewürzmischung für das fleisch und zwar
jeweils einen teelöffel chili thymian
und minze einem halben teelöffel
kreuzkümmel zwei esslöffel süßes
paprikapulver und einen esslöffel salz
so spd ist die freistellung zubereitet
dafür nimmt jetzt das gemüse ich hab
zwei zwiebeln reichen aus um einen
richtig waschen und nehmen sie auch dass
sie und die zwiebeln sonst die
paprikaschoten werden jetzt in feine
streifen geschnitten
[Musik]
das klein geschnittene gemüse gebe ich
es mit drei esslöffel öl in einem großen
topf und da wird jetzt für etwa acht
minuten angebraten und in der
zwischenzeit kann ich mich schon mal um
fleisch geworden
das fleisch ist so ein richtig schönes
großes stück und dann nehme ich jetzt
hier oben die silber haut weg aber das
was ich dran dadurch wird vielleicht
nämlich richtig schön saftig
und jetzt schneide ich es ein und da
müsste jetzt einfach aufpassen dass ihr
das fleisch ist nicht auseinander
schneidet sondern wir wollen einfach ein
paar schnitzereien schneiden für die
füllung das heißt einmal hier quer und
dann auch längst
[Musik]
und das fleisch hatte ich übrigens
bereits vor 2 stunden aus dem
kühlschrank geholt das ist es gar nicht
mehr so ganz kalt hat er raumtemperatur
und so hat einfach die perfekte weiter
verarbeitungs temperatur
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich hier in einer schüssel
alte gewürze zusammenmischen all die
gewürze die gewürze also alle gewürze
ihr wisst was ich meine
so hat die hälfte kommt jetzt hier
zwischen rhein das heißt die schnitte
als nächstes nämlich jetzt die paprika
polo die umsätze noch gewürzt werden mit
salz und pfeffer
hier findet auch richtig schön weich auf
die idee kommen jetzt auch mit hier
einfach nur so viel wir ein fast
das nehme ich noch das restliche öl und
nimmt einfach in die hand und kann jetzt
das fleisch damit einreiben
das heißt die außenseiten und jetzt
kommt hier noch das restliche gewürz
drüber und wird so ein bisschen
einmassiert
damit das fleisch es nicht
auseinanderfällt könnt ihr jetzt
entweder küchengarn nehmen und es so
zusammen bin und so dass wir einfach
wieder diese ursprüngliche form haben
oder lebt einfach einen bräter der
einfach klein genug ist das heißt ich
nehme jetzt hier einfach mehr glas auch
noch die schule meine hände sind rot
aber das ist nicht schlimm
und da fühle ich jetzt zuerst einmal das
restliche gemüse ein
sozusagen als battle für das fleisch
da legen wir jetzt das große stück drauf
und so kommt das fleisch ist in den
backofen
und zwar habe ich jetzt hier schon ein
backblech und stellen diese partie drauf
und jetzt könnt ihr das hier für etwa
zwei stunden bei 160 grad garen
ich werde sogar noch mit einem
thermometer überwachen
das kann ich jetzt hier außen nämlich
einstecken und hier habe ich drei solche
sensoren das heißt an drei verschiedenen
punkten werde die temperatur von fleisch
gemessen
und ich nehme das jetzt hier raus und
sticht einfach so in die mitte
und dann können sich einfach im backofen
einschalten und die küche wieder sauber
machen und einfach zu erwarten
jetzt ist das fleisch trotz der backofen
hat gepatzt
und so sieht momentan aus und die zweite
ich um einfach so ein bisschen groß zu
bekommen das thermometer entfernen haus
nimmt und jetzt einfach mal die
kursstufe einschalten das könnt ihr dann
auch machen und dann noch mal für etwa 5
minuten bei grin stufe bei der höchsten
hitze die ihr habt einfach noch mal
grillen damit die kruste so ein bisschen
auf dunkler wird in der zwischenzeit
zeige ich euch schon mal die restlichen
zutaten zum fertig stellen brauche ich
kartoffeln ich habe jetzt hier ein kilo
kartoffeln nehme jetzt einfach drei
große die sind bereits vorgekocht 3 bis
4 2
ich habe ich noch drei esslöffel butter
schmalz eine knoblauchzehe 500 gramm
joghurt mit zehn prozent fettgehalt man
halben teelöffel salz und etwas pfeffer
ich habs jetzt die kartoffeln wie gesagt
bereits vorgekocht ein bisschen abkühlen
lassen
ihr könnt natürlich auch kleinere mengen
arbeit hatte jetzt nur die da deswegen
sind die so riesig und die werde ich
jetzt das heißt die schale wegnehmen
[Musik]
die kartoffeln schneide ich jetzt in
dicke scheiben so etwa zwei zentimeter
dick und ich habe ich bereits
butterschmalz in die pfanne gegeben dann
nehme ich jetzt eine reifenpanne
da kann man wirklich am besten drin
braten und wettet auf mittel hoher hitze
erhitzen und die kartoffeln dann darin
anbraten
jetzt ist steinbach hat auch perfekt zum
essen da da kommt immer dann wenn es
erst mal gehabt das ist echt echt
passiert
die sweg ich hier die kartoffeln einfach
rein und wenn sie von beiden seiten
knusprig anbraten und zwar so lange bis
ihr durch sind das heißt nämlich so
einfach mal eine gabel nehmen oder ein
messer ein stechen und einfach schaue ob
sie gar sind
und dann werde ich gleich noch den
rosmarin nehmen und die nadeln abzug
klein hacken und späteren darüber geben
das heißt so dass er einfach nicht
verbrennen
während die kartoffeln hier noch braten
und es riecht hier wirklich schon
unglaublich lecker ich habe schon
richtig worauf kann ich jetzt hier schon
mal dass tasci vorbereiten dafür nehme
ich jetzt den cremigen joghurt und
eignet sich da auch echt am besten da
ist schön stichfest und schmeckt uns
persönlich am besten weil es ein
bisschen knoblauch ein
ich nehme es auch gar nicht die ganze
zählen das ist mir ein bisschen zu viel
soll wirklich nur ganz leicht nach
knoblauch schmecken
ich hoffe dass mein bruder heute nicht
vorbei kommt der ist nämlich kein
knoblauch jetzt kurz rühren mit salz und
pfeffer würzen
wer möchte kann hier noch ist im winter
dazu geben oder eine burka zum beispiel
das nicht auch super lecker und es hat
sich hier stelle ich jetzt mal kurz
kunst wäre dass die kartoffeln wenden
damit ihr nicht zu dunkel werden und
dann kann gleich alles angerichtet
werden
so sieht der rat nichts aus ich habe
jetzt hier schon mal ein stückle
weggeschnitten für den murat natürlich
müssen die kartoffeln noch gewürzt
werden mit salz und pfeffer installation
meersalz und hab das jetzt hier schon
mit 20 an gerichten sich mehr salz haben
nein ich hab dir schon mehr salz drauf
und das rezept ist wirklich super
einfach und was ich noch sagen wollte
viele denken ja bei kebab direkt an der
keeper vor also anderen bürger dem aus
der hand ist und immer bezeichnet
eigentlich nur fleischgericht das heißt
so können ganz viele verschiedene
gerichte halten denn hardcover preis
daneben drehen da kevins jahren könne
heißt es dreht sich übrigens genau und
so bezeichnet man dann einfach das
gericht was man in vielen imbissbuden
bekommt und das hier ist einfach jetzt
ein camp auf gerecht und probier bevor
es kalt wird ihre rezepte kennst du ja
schon machen wir ja und ich habe jetzt
auch noch ein bisschen brühe übrig habe
das jetzt einfach in der
offen gelassen habe es noch mal im
backofen die brühe können wir natürlich
weiter verwenden um eine suppe zu machen
oder eine soße draus zuzubereiten
also dies aber wirklich super lecker und
ja ich verstehe nicht warum mir und mir
ein buttermesser gibt um damit fleisch
zu schneiden schuldig und stadt besser
ausgesehen auf dem vorjahr aus doch auch
gut und ich bin ja da habe ich einfach
weiter essen ja dazu nichts mehr sagen
doch nach dem buch die macht spieler
abstellen und solche rezepte oder so
ähnliche rezepte findet ihr nämlich auch
in meiner mediterranen kochbuch da gibt
es wirklich ganz ganz viele verschiedene
rezepte auch vegetarisches vorspeisen
desserts und da muss ich auch sagen wir
auch jedes einzelne rezept echt genial
oder einfach im schnitt somit nur
einfach zum aufzügen lassen essen mit
lang sind okay machen wir weil sie das
rezept nach machen möchte dann schaut
auch sallys - block date vorbei da steht
noch mal alles ganz genau und ich
menschlich war für nachmachen und guten
appetit und bis zum nächsten mal ist es
hat irgendwie 300 gramm fleisch wirklich
leid aber es schmeckt so lecker ich kann
echt möglich was ist das artist sich die
zeit jetzt muss haben irak geholt
[Musik]
schatz mischkost eingefallen wie nennt
man auf türkisch zu flughafen habe meine
mama sagt kebab morath kein typischer
unterwegs war naja sollte mal erzählte
nach hinzuschauen einverstanden kebab
trieb ab